If you like the Witcher video games, there's
a lot you'll like on the Netflix series, too.
But if you fell in love with Geralt, Ciri,
Yennefer and the rest with a controller in
your hand, you'll find a few surprises waiting
in the TV adaptation of these classic Polish
books.
One of the best characters in CD Projekt Red's
games and Andrzej Sapkowski's novels is the
fashionable, womanizing bard Dandelion, who's
somehow one of Geralt's closest friends despite
his penchant for getting into trouble.
"He could die."
"*gasp* F---.
Geralt —"
"Uh… yeah.
We won't let that happen."
He's just as delightful in the TV show, although
you might not immediately recognize him.
In Netflix's The Witcher, he goes by a different
name.
Instead of Dandelion, The Witcher calls the
character Jaskier.
"Well, that makes sense, insomuch that it
sort of… doesn't."
There's a good reason for this.
In the novels' original Polish, "Jaskier"
is actually Dandelion's name, and translates
in English to "Buttercup."
In the games, the name Dandelion fit well,
but the bard's flamboyant personality has
been toned down for the show.
Jaskier is still a scene-stealing rascal,
but he's not quite as extravagant as the Dandelion
in the games.
The Netflix show generally has a more serious,
grounded tone, and a silly name like Dandelion
would stick out like a sore thumb.
"Your man might have mentioned that the road
was too narrow for horses in his original
sales pitch."
"Welcome to the world, Jaskier."
For many fans, Doug Cockle is Geralt of Rivia.
The actor has played the Witcher for a dozen
years, voicing Geralt all three games, the
card-based spinoff Gwent, and in guest appearances
in Soulcalibur 6 and Monster Hunter: World.
"Come on, let's do this."
Before Henry Cavill took the lead role for
the Witcher TV series, he was just another
fan of the video games, and he didn't copy
Cockle's performance for his take on the character.
For one, Cavill is British, and in the show
he speaks with something close to his natural
accent.
His tone of voice is also deeper than Cockle's,
whom Cavill has described as having more of
a whispery delivery.
"I wasn't going to make him American, like
Doug Cockle performed him in The Witcher.
And so I kind of blended my natural accent
with that gravelly tone that Doug uses."
Cavill's Geralt doesn't sound the same, but
it still sounds right.
That's what really matters.
"It's not easy being a Witcher.
Trust me — I'd know."
In the Witcher games, Geralt carries two swords;
There's the steel one for regular fights,
and the silver one for fighting monsters.
In the show, that hasn't changed, but you're
not going to see Geralt with two swords strapped
to his back very often.
For the most part, Cavill's Geralt only carries
around one sword at a time.
That's a note that comes straight from the
books, in which Geralt tends to leave his
silver sword on his horse, Roach, unless it's
a very special occasion.
It's also a practical concern, according to
the Witcher show's supervising armorer, Nick
Jeffries.
As Jeffries said in an interview with Polygon,
silver is a soft and flimsy material, and
wouldn't do much good during battle.
It's also pricey, and would attract bandits.
Geralt already has enough trouble.
He doesn't need more.
In fact, all of the weapons and costumes on
the show are more grounded than their video
game counterparts.
What works in a digital world doesn't always
work in live action, and the costume designers
behind the TV show deliberately turned away
from games' style, making costumes and accessories
more grounded and practical.
They may not be quite as visually memorable,
but they hold up a lot better in a fight.
The Witcher has a lot of backstory to get
through, and unlike the games, it has to appeal
to an audience that's not always willing to
buy into fantasy.
Series showrunner Lauren Schmidt Hissrich
told Looper,
"You don't want to alienate people who've
never heard of The Witcher before.
[...] I wanted to make sure I was giving it
in bite sized-pieces."
As such, some of the characters that you know
from the games have been combined, or given
new roles.
For example, the wizard Mousesack or Ermion,
as the game calls him can be found in The
Witcher 3, which takes place after the events
of the TV series and the books.
He won't play a similar role in the show,
though, since - spoiler alert - he's killed
halfway through the first season.
You're going to run into that sort of thing
a lot familiar characters or personalities,
but remixed in a way that makes them feel
fresh or new.
Triss Merigold is one of the very first people
you meet in the first Witcher game, where
she's positioned as Geralt's main love interest.
In The Witcher 3, when Geralt's on-again,
off-again girlfriend Yennefer finally shows
up, the game embraces a legitimate love triangle.
Players have to choose which of the two sorceresses
they want to romance.
Both make a strong case.
Just don't try to double-dip in the end, you'll
regret it.
Well, if you're team Triss, we have some bad
news: While Yennefer is a major character
on the show, Triss is only a bit part, and
she and Geralt don't have many sparks.
As far as Netflix's series is concerned, Yennefer
is Geralt's one and only.
It's a shame to lose all that juicy drama,
but honestly, The Witcher is busy enough as
it is.
A love triangle is a nice way to break up
a 90-hour game, but show only has eight episodes.
There are more important things to spend that
time on.
If you only know Geralt and Yennefer's romance
from The Witcher 3, you probably think a genie
made them fall in love.
After all, that's the main thrust of the sidequest
"The Last Wish," which serves as a sequel
to the Sapkowski short story of the same name.
In the quest, Geralt and Yennefer hunt a djinn
in order to undo the wish that bound the two
together.
When you succeed, you can either continue
romancing Yennefer or dump her.
It's your call.
The game implies that magic made Geralt and
Yennefer get together.
On the show, it's a lot more complicated.
Like, a lot.
Episode five, "Bottled Appetites," depicts
Geralt and Yennefer's first meeting, and while
it does feature Geralt saving Yennefer's life
by calling on a djinn, the wish itself is
ambiguous.
As in the books, you don't hear exactly what
Geralt wished for.
Further, it's pretty clear in the show that
Geralt has feelings for Yennefer.
The elf Chireadan flat-out says as much, and
Geralt and Yennefer's mutual attraction turns
out to be important to the plot.
Geralt risks his life for Yennefer because
he likes her, and Yennefer's flirty dialogue
hints that she feels the same way.
The genie might seal the deal, but the sparks
are already flying.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
movies and TV shows are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.